uh guess who oh is that my host behind  me it certainly is  lovely to make your acquaintance this is  true cameras are rolling  welcome to the first live sitcom taping  in marvel studios history  i haven't been in front of a live  audience since 1884.  oh is that right yeah  the first time i heard about the concept  i thought it was brilliant it's such a  homage to americans it comes throughout  the 20th century  the marvel mcu is the largest episodic  experiment ever  when you're on these big films and you  get all those pieces moving it feels  really special  it's such a beautiful puzzle box  so excited to finally be able to say  this out loud  it's gonna be so exciting for our fans  to dissect the way it  are in unravels  waters  marvel studios assembled the making of  one division original special now  streaming and stream all one division  episodes only on disney plus